What's up guys. I'm Brendan sharp from the fighter and the kid and Showtime.
Um.
$4 Billion to be on catch-up editor.
Would you rather lose the sensitivity flavor of your taste buds or lose a
sensitive feeling of sex? Oh,
I'll go with, you know, I'm getting a little older. I'd go with sex. You know,
I love food. I love pizza. I'm getting a tad older.
It would calm me down. If I didn't care about sex,
probably be more focused in life. I'll take the, uh, the sex. Yeah,
definitely a second. Who is the one president you'd want to get faced with?
This is easy pill, Clinton,
that old scallywag he's a good time, man.
Him Monica Lewinsky. I want him to how he cheated on his girl.
Non-stop as the president of United States and just slapping, uh, bill Clinton,
would you rather have a good hand job from your grandma? Good God guys.
Or a bad hand job from your grandmother?
A bad one. Obviously you don't want it. Good.
Cause you want to be thinking about it the next week. You want to be like, ah,
that was terrible. Old Brinkley hands.
These are now I'm scared to read this.
Would you rather have your porn search history shared with all your Twitter
followers or your parents' Twitter followers? Because they're dirt bags like me.
They're like, Oh dude, you think that's hot? Check this out.
That would be the best. My parents would judge the out of me.
My Twitter followers would love me even more for it.
If you were a war general in the civil war and you got the choice of bringing a
T-Rex or more, uh, modern war tank on your side, what are you taking?
Is it, is it during the civil war? Well, I thought it was today. I was like,
today I'm taking a drone, just civil war that T-Rex just like, ah,
it's like killing everyone. And then like,
and then all the guys are putting muskets like, Oh. Yeah.
I'll take the T-Rex now. I thought at the time,
current day I'd blow the shut thing today. He's laughing. It's just not good.
[Inaudible].
Oh man. Would you take, take,
take $4 billion to be on catch-up predator?
Nah, man. No, I don't need the cash that bad. I'm good, man.
I don't need that reputation that your whole game would be killed.
There's no jobs. There's nothing. No, I will not take four mil. No, no,
not take 4 million VX. That's your predator.
That's hilarious.
No, you just the whole, I don't want,
I don't want him coming to the whole awkward thing. Him going.
You want to sit down like for one he's like, he's like we got here.
Uh, you said you want to lick his he's 14. I don't want that. And you have,
Mike's hard lemonade in the truck, sir. Yeah, no, no.
Uh, I'd have to ride off the sunset. Never be seen again.
I'll say a hundred mil.
A hundred mil, a hundred mil. Do it.
Well, I'll just become like the blitz. Aaron, you know,
fricking to catch predator. I've had like this crazy Instagram. It's like,
you guys.
So if you were offered a sum of money or you could choose one somebody or
world peace, what's this sum of money you take?
I don't think there's a, uh,
the nice guy answer is I don't think there's a similar money, uh,
for world P God dang. I mean there's certain point.
How much money do you need? You're gonna check all the boxes.
So he say a billion dollars. You kind of set, you say 50 billion doesn't matter.
So.
No. Nope, Nope, Nope, no comment. Nice job.